prezzo ma bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj sto per giocare start assignment si
fa così avete presente nei videogiochi
horror tipo quando in un horror capita
che ti staccano degli arti che rimangono
per terra insomma tipo così vi siete mai
fatti la domanda ma chi dice che pulisce
ecco questo gioco è fighissimo perché
devi pulire le cose che sporcano gli
mostri
ecco potuto pulito il mio compito è
quello di pulire le cose non stai bene
va bene ma è ancora vivo quello non si
agiti sono qua per salvarla prenda
questo bidone
ecco qua sei più calmo perché stai
meglio perché ti ho schiacciato sei
morto di nuovo proviamo nei una serie
ragazzi facciamo questo che mi sembra
più firme lo avete visto come funziona
devo pulire devo devo pulire perfetto
credo ragazzi che ci sia stato un
delitto una roba del gela madonna bene
ma è una roba di halloween magari
l'hanno fatto apposta perché devo
svuotare il secchio ogni volta ma che
cazzo i problemi ora iniziamo subito col
pianerottolo di fuori perfetto ecco
adesso mi sa dire che hanno sporcato di
nuovo no che cazzo sta roba che guanti
fashion che hai zio mi fa piacere
[Musica]
ma [ __ ] mi sono sempre chiesto chi
è che pulisce negli horror solo che non
l'amato era ma torna live e sono della
disinfestazione poi posso aprire in
qualche modo giorno lo so che è occupata
però mi farebbe la cortesia di aprire la
porta che c'è una zucca che sta bussando
tra l'altro non ho ben capito come si
apre la porta però che posso aprirla io
di mio meraviglioso e signora zucca mi
spiace cazzo ma danno veramente mi
chiama sono impedito e signora mi scuso
quale non voglio disturbare la prossimi
dice dov'è il bagno posso riempire salve
un appello a tutti i ragazzi del mondo
quando la vostra tipa a il periodo tocca
a voi pulire il divano bagno giorno
anche a lei era mandate cazzo successo
qua lavandino qualcosa per riempire il
secchio no non essere triste devo solo
capire dove sta minchia di madonna ma
perché c'era sull'ultima cena con gesù
che ha una faccia alquanto bizzarra
questa nicchia di bagno sarà da qualche
parte
buongiorno che casse tipo shining carta
haters di merda a è morto mi dispiace
non voler allora ho trovato il bagno che
avevi il maestro anche tu pulisco su di
te però
no no no no no stai pure li avete preso
un po troppo sul serio halloween ragazzi
cioè ve lo dico sì decisamente troppo
sul serio il sangue arriva da questa
stanza ragazzi ho paura ad aprire in
qualche stanza deve entrare
non ci posso credere continua ri
continuerà all'infinito sta cosa
buongiorno salve sto seguendo le chiazze
di sangue va bene non è vero apro e
uguale identica la mia tra l'altro
probabilmente qualcuno dovrà pulire la
mia casa tra non molto è sempre vero che
un uomo ama la sua donna in ogni periodo
dell'anno però magari non fatelo se la
tipa le cose e poi conclusa the letto
almeno quello che a [ __ ] quanto
difficile trovare un secchio
mi scusi sono disturbata c'è un
tritacarne in giardino o dio fatemi
uscire lega non ho ancora visto niente
io in poche parole dai ragazzi facciamo
le cose fatte bene
iniziamo con criterio o che è il
pianerottolo è andato questa via
senti frate facciamo così guarda per te
conte risparmiano spazio apposito
aspem anche al coperchio ok niente koper
si può aprire questo a qualcuno mi da un
secchio per corte la madonna lio bar che
fa se non lo sai usare sto tagliaerba
non lo sa usare qualcuno voglia di
spiegarmi chi è stato a fare queste cose
per l'amor di dio
grazie a enti zia prova a vedere se sta
roba funziona l'avevo già doppiata prima
ma a quanto pare che eva i vestiti nuovi
non ho visto dov'è finita la tizia ma
vabbè la o matic è una generatrice di
secchi se ha ringraziato i tiro quindi
vuol dire che se
perfetto grazie che ha messo le mani
sulla porta porca eva
guardi che costa al servizio di pulizia
e regolo faccio gratis
facciamo un piccolo sconto va allora
vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa di
decente perfetto brava zia perfetto
datemi una mano co star o qualcuno si
connetta stop che poi il bello è che si
può giocare anche in multiplayer
ok perfetto ce l'abbiamo fatta posso
fare ancora sto tizio minchia c'è palle
ci ho messo un'ora e mezza solo per il
garage ragazzi madonna che bordello ma
cos'è e vabbè ma come ha fatto a
sporcarsi di più in tutto questo c'è
ancora un punto che non abbiamo visto
che il giardino sul retro ma ancora c'è
una casa dietro la casa veramente è
permesso ecco è chiusa pure può sapere
ma è sporco dentro dopo lire mi scusi
buon uomo non è che mi può aprire che
non posso entrare io sono quella chiazza
lassù mi spieghi come minchia la pulisco
come ci arrivo ce l'ho fatta
la cover se lo fate ragazzi di
importante pulire e poi dicono che il
lavoro dello youtuber è un lavoro poco
faticoso ma [ __ ] posto finito beh
ma che bello sai tranquillo ragazzi miei
ditemi se qua non ci metto tre anni a
pulire come faccio spiegatemi devo
puntarci mon ami per pulire nanì chiara
si è sporcato troppo al secchio fango
prende pure l'acqua nuova porca [ __ ]
laida ladra quando intendevo scopare non
intendevo questo come un ragazzino nei
video faccio un miliardo di tagli ma vi
assicuro che un'ora che sorprende sono
solo fuori il caso ancora non ho pulito
niente cena galante ci metterò una vita
il tetto andato questo andato ci sono
poi di viscere per terra è proprio da
buttare l'immondizia anche no perché
vuota
no no no no mi sei sporca stai sporcando
stai sporca esci breve pezzo ma gioco di
merda sentite fatemi entrare in casa a
vedere cosa riesca of madonna quanti
secchi cos'è sta roba ragazzi che ancora
non ho capito ai tre location
adesso ho capito come faceva arrivare la
sua se io in questo momento resetto la
mappa da zero e più pulita di prima
allora mi spiegate chi è stato perché
qualcuno ci avrà la colpa lo devo
ammazzare anch'io quello poi pulisco
promesso però fatemelo ammazzare chi
cazzo è stato nostro spettacoli
tranquillo ho colpito qualcosa ha fatto
un casino incredibile però non ho visto
neanche cosa va bene cucina pulita
caccia è vavalà fan culo visto rotto il
cazzo sentite e basta fare questa cosa
mi stressa mi mangio kg di noci vuoi
favorire zio no bene meglio per me
un'ora e mezza che pulisco cose mi sento
meriti di morire atrocemente un ora per
pulire guardare bordello guarda vabbè
ragazzi non ho idea di come c'e
veramente dori passarci quattro ore in
una casa sola per pulirla c rendetevi
conto però è figo c'è l'idea del gioco è
veramente [ __ ] ufficio questo è il mio
ufficio a ecco mi ha dato e mi ha dato
il risultato della performance di prima
performance meno 3 per cento
si parte dallo 0 per cento preso un po
per arrivare al 100 per cento di pulizia
significa che ho sporcato più di quanto
non fosse sporco all'inizio avere
casuali spero che video vi sia piaciuto
è stato alquanto istruttivo almeno sei
entrato in casa e trovate un casino del
genere sapete come pulire
spero che viene vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
questo era il mio tutorial su come
pulire in caso di devastazione consensi
mio vissuto su un argomento è un mi
piace anche a pace di facebook e
camminino trascrizione so se si discute
di civiltà un prossimo vinto dai ragazzi